suny lee is coming home from the tokyo
olympics to some
very excited fans the gold medal winning
olympian was greeted by a large group of
admirers at the today plaza in new york
city ahead of her appearance on the show
and met one fan who could hardly hold
back his tears
in the sweet clip shared to twitter suny
greets and takes a picture with a young
boy
who has a poster of the gymnast in his
hand the 12 year old fan's mom
also shared to suny what it meant for
her son to be meeting her
[Music]
in minnesota okay come on
you're so sweet the emotions didn't stop
there
while on today the 18 year old athlete
was also reunited with her own parents
and siblings
whom she had not seen since before the
olympics
just tell us what it was like seeing him
for the first time amazing i haven't
seen him in so long so
to see them here and be with me in new
york is absolutely amazing and just
i feel so proud i'm so happy to see them
suny's family watched her winning run
from minnesota along with a group of
nearly 400 fans
who poured in to cheer on their hometown
olympian
[Applause]
the athlete made history at the tokyo
olympics being the first
hmong american gymnast to qualify for
the olympics and the first asian
american woman to win gold in the
all-around
while on today suny took a moment at
their reunion to place her medals around
the necks of her mother
and father who were beaming with pride
oh my god
i never ever thought that i would ever
get one of these
and she did it she got it she brought
her home e.t spoke with today anchors
hoda copy and savannah guthrie after
they caught up with suny and the rest of
the women's gymnastics team
including simone biles this is the first
time they've actually heard this kind of
applause
and this kind of love and adoration
which is something you usually get at
the olympic games they
they literally performed in a quiet area
not that quiet because hoda was cheering
and she's like she's like 10 people
i love these girls and i think there is
something about you know when your
parents can't be there and you're at a
very vulnerable time
like i i don't know we any mom would
feel it we all feel it like you want to
help them you want to make it better
right after i think it was sunni she was
down in the interview zone and
she said can i have a hug yeah just hold
it for a hug
it's like well of course you know you we
want to hug we all want to hug these
girls they're amazing and
what they did is incredible and what
they did without their normal
family and friends and the big teammates
and the cheers is
even all the more incredible coda also
revealed to et that she had an amazing
experience flying back with a team from
tokyo
it was super fun i was getting ready to
get on the plane and i see them all
they're like so little and they've got
these huge bags and i was like
oh my god and they've just they put
their heart on the table
in tokyo and they finally were starting
to rest and there was something about
seeing them i was like you okay
everyone's sleeping you're eating you're
drinking good good good all right
everyone 99 let's go
simone slept 11 hours on the flight 11
and i would know
because i was watching to make sure
hello
she's like she's still here you